Trascrizione: Eleonora Fantinel
Revisore: Anna Cristiana Minoli
Una delle cose che dico sempre quando
mi devo presentare è: sono veneziana.
E io credo che questo sia un fatto
che in un certo senso
caratterizza tutti i veneziani,
perché tutti i veneziani
sentono il bisogno di dire a gran voce
che provengono da una città
diversa da tutte le altre.
E perché?
Perché succede?
Eh, perché purtroppo sono effettivamente
sempre più rari e, forse, ancora di più,
perché Venezia in un certo senso
ti entra dentro, ti riempie.
Tu sei un vaso e lei è l’acqua che idrata
letteralmente i tuoi pensieri.
Quando cresci,
fisicamente o ancora di più
intellettualmente, a Venezia,
camminando per le sue calli
e attraversando i suoi campi, alzandoti
e abbassandoti al ritmo
delle acque alte, non hai scelta.
Sei legato per sempre a questa città,
alla sua forma, alla sua architettura,
al dolce peso della sua storia.
Ma, soprattutto, sei legato
al suo modo di insegnarti
a interpretare i problemi e i limiti.
E questa città ne ha di limiti.
Però tu impari a vedere questi limiti
non come dei punti di debolezza,
ma come dei punti di forza.
E infatti Venezia,
per la sua conformazione fisica
particolarissima,
naturale e artificiale allo stesso tempo,
e per la sua incredibiile particolarità
architettonica e costruttiva,
non è soltanto
una città bellissima.
Venezia in un certo senso rappresenta una
una direzione,
una rotta, una possibilità
verso una vita più sostenibile
e a misura d’uomo.
Mi rendo conto che questo possa
non essere l’immaginario comune.
La maggior parte delle persone,
pensando a Venezia, pensa
a una città estremamente complessa
estremamente scomoda,
piena di barriere architettoniche
e vincoli edilizi,
costretta ad una mobilità lenta
e quindi inefficiente.
Ma è davvero così?
Da sempre gli architetti, nel cercare
di trasformare lo spazio
per renderlo a misura d’uomo,
si sono interrogati su come fare.
E la misura utilizzata in principio
per rendere lo spazio adatto alla vita
è stata letteralmente quella umana.
Pensiamo banalmente al piede
come unità di misura
che è utilizzata ancora oggi.
E questo ovviamente è successo
anche a Venezia,
quando si è trattato di costruire Venezia.
E la misura usata è stata
quella umana anche in questo caso.
E oggi, forse ancora più
che in un passato recente,
Venezia si trova a racchiudere
al suo interno tutte quelle misure
che gli architetti innovatori e i mecenati
visionari cercano di disegnare
e di teorizzare
all’interno della città del futuro.
Mobilità completamente pedonale,
servizi raggiungibili
nell’arco di 20 minuti a piedi al massimo,
servizi di collegamento pubblico urbano
interno alla città,
valorizzazione della dimensione
sociale e dell’interazione tra le persone,
natura al centro e protagonista,
sostenibilità
e utilizzo di risorse rinnovabili.
Ecco, questi che vi
ho appena elencato
sono i punti fondamentali
del programma di The Line
che, per chi non la conoscesse,
è l’ultima arrivata tra i progetti
di città futuristiche ideali che forse
vedremo sorgere nei prossimi anni.
Chi lo sa, nel deserto?
Ripeto, nel deserto dell'Arabia Saudita.
Se ci pensate bene, fatta eccezione
per la sostenibilità e l’utilizzo
di risorse rinnovabili
che è effettivamente
un work in progress un po’ per tutti,
tutti gli altri punti della checklist
Venezia li ha già,
a Venezia bisogna utilizzare
il proprio corpo
per muoversi, per camminare.
E questo può essere un esercizio forse
scomodo, però estremamente salutare.
A Venezia tutti i servizi sono
raggiungibili nell’arco di 20 minuti
o poco più, perché Venezia
è estremamente piccola
e a Venezia il collegamento interno
alla città, come servizio pubblico,
forse non tutti lo sanno, ma è arrivato
addirittura con dieci anni d’anticipo
rispetto a quanto è successo
nella terraferma.
I primi vaporini, o vaporetti come li
chiamiamo oggi,
risalgono addirittura al 1891
con dieci anni di anticipo
rispetto a quello che è successo
con i Tramway
Elettrici di Terraferma.
E questo, secondo me, è un fatto
che ci mostra come Venezia
sia stata in grado
e sia ancora oggi in grado di adattarsi
a quelle che sono le nuove esigenze
sotto la spinta, ovviamente,
del progresso tecnico.
E a Venezia l’interazione sociale
è garantita.
La mobilità lenta lo aiuta,
bisogna camminare
e camminando ci si incontra,
si parla, ci si scambia idee.
A Venezia -
Scusatemi, io sto perdendo il microfono.
E comunque io farò una cosa,
permettetemi, ma-
Eccomi allora, come dicevo,
a Venezia l’interazione sociale
è garantita proprio dalla mobilità lenta
e a Venezia
la natura è protagonista.
Come ci ha detto Jain, la vita della città
dipende dalla vitalità della laguna.
L'una non può esistere senza l'altra.
E proprio in questo senso la sinergia
tra uomo e natura deve essere portata
ai massimi livelli possibili.
E proprio questo fatto
ci mostra come
Venezia, appunto, abbia tanti punti
in comune con The Line.
Però ce n’è uno, ce n’è uno che Venezia
non ha per fortuna in comune con The Line,
ossia Venezia ha un un passato.
Venezia non è una città costruita
di punto in bianco.
Venezia è un palinsesto,
una tela su cui artisti, architetti
o semplicemente esseri umani
hanno sovrapposto
la loro tecnica e la loro esperienza.
E questa esperienza di vita è leggibile,
è leggibile su ogni pietra,
su ogni laterizio
dell’architettura della città.
Ecco perché penso che gli architetti
abbiano un ruolo molto importante,
che è quello di valorizzare e tutelare
questo patrimonio edilizio storico
e di trasferirne il valore.
Trasferire il valore di questa
sovrapposizione di vite e di esperienze
a chi nell’architettura storica
piuttosto vede un limite, un limite
dato dal fatto
di non poter sempre raggiungere
tutti quegli standard
di comodità ed efficienza
e che quindi la fanno sembrare
meno efficiente, appunto,
di una città completamente nuova.
Ecco perché, accanto a questo,
alla sostenibilità economica,
sociale e ambientale,
io penso esista anche
un altro tipo di sostenibilità,
una sostenibilità
che provo a definire come umanistica.
Perché Venezia,
proprio per la sua conformazione
fisica, può diventare un esempio
di questa sostenibilità, perché
è nata in un in un momento, in un momento
in cui la storia e il pensiero umano
era al centro della --
scusatemi, ho perso il filo del discorso.
Volevo dire che Venezia può diventare
un esempio
di questa sostenibilità umanistica
perché la sua conformazione fisica
particolarissima
l’ha preservata dalla maggior parte
dei cambiamenti strutturali che invece
hanno caratterizzato le più note
città del nostro mondo.
E quindi come una sorta di Pompei vivente
ha permesso ai suoi cittadini
di continuare a vivere
in un ambiente che è nato
in un momento in cui l’uomo era
al centro del pensiero e non la macchina
e quindi era il centro dell’architettura,
dell’arte, dell’economia e della politica.
E ed è per questo che credo che Venezia
ci stia lanciando
un messaggio molto forte.
L’ambizione dell’uomo del futuro
nel cercare
di migliorare la sua condizione umana
non è quella di rivoluzionare
completamente
il proprio modo di vivere
in virtù dell’efficienza e della comodità.
L'ambizione dell'uomo del futuro,
piuttosto, è quella di riuscire a vivere
secondo la misura umana e la misura umana
non è l'efficienza, che invece è proprio
della macchina, la misura umana è
la capacità di esprimere sé stesso
all'interno di uno spazio.
E Venezia può permettere di esprimersi
al massimo, perché in un certo senso
è estremamente ergonomica,
nel senso letterale del termine che è dato
dall'unione delle parole greche ergon,
lavoro e nomos, regola.
Quindi quando dico, Venezia è ergonomica
intendo dire che Venezia consente
di lavorare e quindi di vivere secondo
quelle regole che col passare dei secoli
sono entrate intimamente
a far parte dell’essenza dell’uomo.
Quindi il rispetto del contesto naturale,
il rispetto dell’anatomia del corpo,
il rispetto della dimensione culturale,
storica e sociale.
E quindi la sostenibilità che bisognerebbe
ricercare in ogni città del futuro
è quella umanistica --
è quella umanistica, perché deve essere
una sostenibilità --
una sostenibilità a tutto tondo
che fonda le sue radici
nella dimensione storico-adattiva
dell’essere umano.
E quindi, se cambiamo prospettiva
e usiamo quella veneziana,
ci rendiamo conto
che Venezia non è scomoda.
Anzi, Venezia continua a indicare a tutti
gli architetti del mondo e non solo
la rotta per la progettazione di
spazi realmente a misura d’uomo.